[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i am going
to explain a post-apocalyptic drama film
called cargo
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
at the start of the film we are
introduced to a couple andy and kaye
along with their one-year-old daughter
rosie in a world ravaged by a virus that
turns people into zombies in 48 hours
they seek refuge on a houseboat in rural
australia while relocating to a safe
space for the night andy spots two
children playing on the riverside he
waves at them and tries to talk with
them but their father spots andy and
draws a revolver from his belt
compelling him to continue on his way
the family is used to getting supplies
from the sea as they are too scared of
traveling to the land later kaye
mentions that their food supplies are
running out and that they should travel
through land to get better supplies
however andy criticizes her decision as
he is scared of what lies on the land
afterward andy discovers an abandoned
sailboat on the riverbank and goes out
to inspect it while he collects some
food and a bottle of wine from inside he
hears some strange noises coming from
within a door despite being curious andy
is unwilling to take any risks and
retreats to his boat he passes the
captured goods over decay but she is
skeptical about the food being the good
husband that he is andy manages to
convince his wife that everything is
fine and he probably should have
mentioned the zombie sounds he heard but
i guess it's not important later kaye
asks andy to take a break and then heads
to the sailboat the greed to salvage
more supplies prompts her to enter the
dangerous yacht alone andy had left
earlier after hearing thuds from a door
but kaye is completely unaware of this
soon she gets pulled and bitten by an
unknown entity most likely a zombie
andy's sleep is disturbed by rosie's
crying and he goes in search of k he
notices some blood stains on the floor
and finds kay trying to keep blood flow
under control she is inside the restroom
and has a bite mark on her knee she then
explores a rucksack that andy had
retrieved from the yacht earlier kay
wears a bracelet that counts down how
much longer an infected has left as well
as an infusion that mitigates the brain
and allows an infected to transition
into a zombie painlessly andy and kaye
discuss their objectives revealing
kaye's vulnerabilities to the family
after the emotional discussion the
family finally makes the decision to
leave the houseboat and seek medical
assistance in the next scene thumy a
little aboriginal girl is shown doodling
in a sketchbook after leaving her house
she tosses a dead rabbit into a hole she
suddenly hears gurgling noises and puts
her hands over her ears it seems like
she is trying to feed something later
andy and kaye locate a car nearby they
nearly dodge a zombie approaching them
as they drive away after some time
driving they stop the car so that andy
can study a map as k starts changing
rosie's diaper just then k drops on the
floor vomiting blood all over the place
andy jumps out of the car and swiftly
calms her down kay appears to be
transforming into a zombie on the other
hand thumy can be seen throwing a snake
into the hole again but this time she
hears no sound
elsewhere k regains her consciousness
and examines her wound which is dripping
yellow sludge she screams at andy as she
gets out of the car outraged that he has
been trying to keep her zombie progress
secret from her she's worried about
infecting their baby daughter despite
his concerns andy calms her and
persuades her to follow him to prevent
kay from making another escape he
smashes the doorknob on the way andy
gets distracted by a weird looking guy
on the road which results in the car
crashing into a tree
hours later andy regains consciousness
and tries to wake k up but finds her
already turned into a zombie her lips
and eyes are filled with yellow pus andy
is frightened and tries to escape with
rosie but gets bitten by her while
attempting to do so after some attempts
andy manages to get out of the car and
applies one of the injections to kaye
before setting out towards the
destination on foot he puts kay's timer
bracelet on himself and straps rosie to
his back the small girl starts crying
and she misses her mother but andy
quickly calms her down by applying kay's
perfume during a short stop for rest
andy discovers the person who caused
their accident he identifies him as a
zombie and prepares to defend himself
suddenly thumy appears and attempts to
distract the zombie guy who turns out to
be her father she requests that andy
stay away from him and cuts her hand
with a rock which begins to drip blood
this seems to attract her zombie father
towards her after some walking andy
enters a school and encounters a retired
instructor named edda she aids him in
washing his wounds and informs him that
all of the aboriginal people in the area
have left including many of her former
students she also requests him to spend
the night at the school later andy
notices a fire nearby started by the
aboriginals and also a woman who is
trying to contact thumy at night andy
gets his first seizure because of the
zombie infection he begins to vomit
blood and passes out the next morning he
wakes up and walks outside to meet edda
who urges him to look for thumy's father
willie as he will look over rosie she
then advises andy to stay away from the
aboriginals as they murder any zombies
or infected who come near them after the
conversation andy heads out once again
on the way andy pauses at some ruins to
give rosie water as he rushes out he
passes several zombies with their heads
buried in the ground one of them rises
and starts pursuing him and he finds a
car and tries to steal it but is stopped
by a guy named vic who protects him from
the zombie who had been following him
vic is stuck beneath a tank and he hands
up the car keys to andy in exchange for
a promise that he will save him first
andy agrees right away and after
removing the weight that had been
squeezing vic he starts the car the two
then rush into the car and race away
leaving the zombies behind in the
following scene vic drives andy to his
sanctuary which was originally a gas
plant outpost where he used to work
lorraine vic's wife is quietly surprised
to meet andy vick then instructs andy to
leave rosie with lorraine so the two men
can work together and hunt some food and
kill some zombies vic believes that once
the country is back to normal people
will crave money again thus his job is
killing groups of zombies and seizing
their belongings
vic baits the zombies by putting healthy
live individuals in cages meanwhile andy
notices vic holding thumy hostage inside
a cage and gets irritated inside the
shelter while lorraine is looking after
rosie and attempting to cheer her up she
discovers some yellow slime-like thing
on her belly vic and andy on the other
hand move to a different cage he uses
organs a radio and blood to attract
zombies which makes andy doubt himself
for a bit after the boys return to the
shelter lorraine discusses cleaning up
rosie briefly as andy plays with his
daughter before putting her in a
temporary cradle his hand starts to
twitch seeing himself in this terrible
condition and knowing that rosie is in
safe hands and he heads outside the
shelter to a lonely place and tries to
kill himself but before he is able to do
so lorraine confronts him and explains
that she is not vick's wife and that vic
rescued himself by allowing her husband
and other gas plant workers to die
as they are conversing vic appears out
of nowhere and uses the butt of his
rifle to knock andy out when andy wakes
up he finds himself in the same cage as
thumy andy then asks doumi to help him
to get out of the cage he devises a
strategy in which he connects raw guts
to a rope attracting a swarm of zombies
when the zombies begin to tug on the
rope the door opens allowing the two to
flee they safely return to the shelter
and persuade lorraine to come along with
them as they try to escape vic emerges
and starts shooting at them lorraine
shows herself and attempts to stop him
but it's too late as vic accidentally
shoots her dead andy follows thumy to
the cage he saw before but the man
inside has vanished they managed to
avoid vic's pursuit and spend the night
in a tiny gorge after freeing each
other's chains they sleep freely
later at night thumi wakes up to heavy
breathing and hides with rosie as andy
rubs his face against blood on the wall
the next morning andy and thumy have a
talk regarding her father's well-being
after andy points out that her father
may never get well thumy storms away in
anger just then thumy discovers her
father straddling on the tree dead andy
arrives to console thumi but fails and
swiftly departs soon he has another
nervous breakdown after he finds out
that he has very little time left before
he completely transforms into a zombie
after some time he attempts to bury his
head in the earth like other zombies
thumy stands by the tree heartbroken but
hears rosie's cry and rushes to her aid
when andy wakes up he is surprised by
thumy who has chosen to assist him in
reaching the river in the next scene
they travel by motorboat to the
campground where andy last saw the
family playing they find an rv and
investigate it but find it empty after
that andy and rosie search for the
family while thumy stays behind andy
finally meets the father but finds out
that he has been infected from a zombie
attack for the second time the man shows
andy his loaded rifle the man then
reveals that there are six bullets in
there two of which andy may retain after
he uses the rest on himself and his
family andy tries to persuade the man
from finishing his family but he fails
while andy is leaving four gunshots can
be heard in the distance he flinches at
the sound of each of them after the
whole family is dead andy takes the gun
and considers whether or not to shoot
himself as andy is contemplating thumy
appears out of nowhere announcing that
she is ready to return to her home she
also suggests that andy follow her so
that he can leave rosie with the
aboriginals following this they set out
together to look for smoke coming from a
nearby hill as they pass through the
train tunnel vic emerges in front of
them thumy hides with rosie inside a
parked truck on the tracks as andy
attempts to distract vic andy shoots
rounds but misses each time as the two
guys become more violent vic emerges
from the shadows after the brawl and
drags thumy from the truck he then
knocks her head on the rails while thumy
lies in agony vic grabs hold of rosie a
limping andy gets up to check on thumy
who is still alive he then finds vic
cradling with rosie he sits near vic and
demands his daughter back at first vic
refuses but he ultimately returns the
child while mourning lorraine's untimely
death the trio then continue their
journey continuing their way towards
their destination andy begins to
transform into a zombie with very little
time left andy begs thumy to promise to
look out for rosie with whom he
exchanges a goodbye fearing that he
might harm someone andy covers his mouth
with a guard he then starts securing his
wrists and wraps the meat from earlier
on a stick suddenly his eyelashes are
sealed shut and he passes out andy has
now transformed into a zombie and all of
his emotions have died despite this he
still carries the two children on his
back as he is drawn in by the chunk of
flesh on the stick eventually they
arrive at the aboriginals camp the
warrior sees andy while thumy and rosie
are hailed by her mother one of the
warriors is about to strike andy with
his spear but sumi intervenes she then
takes kei's perfume bottle and gives it
one final spritz andy is briefly brought
back to awareness by the aroma which
reminds him that rosie is now in safe
hands following that thumy ultimately
allows the warrior to put andy out of
his misery in the final scene the
aboriginal people are shown traveling to
a shelter where they are received warmly
by several members of the tribe rosie is
being examined by thumy and her mother
when they see the words thank you
scrawled in white paint on her tummy
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching